i'm anthony joy correspondent for the
Financial Times in Indonesia that was
moderating the session on maintaining
growth momentum the key conclusions of
our session where that in order to
expand and develop in the Asian business
there needs to be significant progress
in infrastructure and legal reform
mostly creating certainty for businesses
business year overall very positive
sentiment about Indonesia's development
and prospects ahead we had social
political and business experts none of
whom or see any major disruptions in the
asian development so I would conclude
the disease's looking like very able to
come and took place to do business with
all the needed changes